[Music]
37 seconds of Sony logos 69a each other
awesome the sky found the original
Jumanji game buried on the beach where
it was left in the last movie but the
people approaching it at the end of the
last movie were speaking French implying
it went across the ocean this is still
America so you you say I found something
you gotta check this out you gotta check
this out cliche board game and play
Spartacus who says this out loud to
themselves when presented with a board
game also tons of people played board
games in 1996 and even now that you what
the hell is exactly going on over there
is there a gremlin masturbating to a
sleeping Alex also wouldn't we think
about Jumanji is its ability to upgrade
whenever someone shuns it this is
something Jumanji stockholders demanded
during the board game crash of 79 say
what Alex was clearly playing a
PlayStation earlier which only plays
discs so why did you Monty settle on
this Atari style upgrade instead of
getting scared and looking for the
asshole who switched the board game for
a video game cartridge this kid thinks
wait a minute maybe I should stick to
some licensed game into my machine and
see what happens
Metallica always taught me not to be
afraid of death man it's bad enough that
Alex had this number of cassette tapes
even in 1996 but in 2017 a teenager like
Spencer has fun CDs huh who knew there
was an extra Kardashian living in New
Hampshire also yes it's 2017 and all
these kids have Sony phones which is
weirdly noticeable at all we just speed
this up free cos makes me very
uncomfortable
my dispenser and fridge meet here
Spencer can give fridge this paper
almost anywhere including at the school
well anyone knowing it's not like he's
your best friend your entire childhood
mumbles position that poor man so awful
it happened to those people
three of the four main characters just
happened to be near the freak house just
before they all get sent to detention
where they will play the Jumanji video
game that directly relates to the family
who used to live here this world
swallows up kids like you damn when Eric
straton became a gynecologist in Beverly
Hills I didn't realize he would get so
cynical I hope that went well but it
will get a glass of buttermilk before
randomly and critically threatened the
next team but why what possible purpose
does bethany being late for fucking gym
class serve not to perpetuate this
utterly useless movie cliche this is
school we are supposed to be learning
things that actually
okay somehow things these kids have
probably done the entire school year
become a big problem on the same day
bethany talks on the phone during a quiz
Martha goes all Lisa Simpson during gym
class and Spencers obvious homework he's
done for fridge is finally discovered
after several attempts it's the last
sentence of Anthony's paper on westward
expansion coincidentally it's the last
sentence of your paper on westward
expansion from last year
this teacher must make copies of her
students papers to reference for
plagiarism later since I thought it was
customary to give the student their
paper back with a grade on it either
that or this teacher out of nowhere
remembers one sentence of a paper from a
year ago or some bullshit yeah you also
used the same metaphor the shredding
wildfire in your papers on the Boston
Tea Party the Battle of Gettysburg and
the woman's suffrage movement man this
teachers played a long con on Spencer
here such a memorable cliche and she
didn't call him out on it once after all
those times yes she knew one day Spencer
would help someone cheek and he'd used
that term and then her master plan would
be complete welcome to detention only
four people got in trouble today one of
the normal rejects at this school also
why is the principal handling detention
he doesn't have better things to do
doesn't that job go to the track coach
or the health teacher or something all
of these old magazines are bound for the
recycling plant it seems all the staples
must be removed what world are you
living in where the staples need to be
removed I guess you could be lying but
why bother I recognize it
so was the game just content to not be
sucking anyone into it for 20 years I
mean the drums weren't even beating to
call attention to the console fridge
just happened to find that I mean the
board game went out of its way to
recruit people so much so they had to
bury that to prevent it from harming
fools I came for those who seek to find
a way to leave their world behind their
reading oh what's fun love it I don't
know I don't think it matters how much
this is of course why the avatars are so
completely conversed to the real-world
characters but why would Spencer say
this when he knows jackpot this game
Franklin moose Finbar it clearly says
mouse but I'm sure this will lead to
hilarious comic I drink later also it's
kind of crazy that this game doesn't
have pictures of the character you were
selecting I'm sure this will lead to
hilarious comic hygiene flater
I think it's now supposedly intelligent
character Spencer does this instead of
you know immediately unplugging the game
why is this game sucking the characters
in at random times so you're telling me
Jumanji has the power to fuse with video
games to become a video game but
doesn't have enough power to take home
for them at the same time ah we just got
sucked into journey to the mysterious
island who you was she how are you guys
I hate to be you that guy wait a minute
I love being that guy but is this how
you talk to people you don't know do you
go to a party find a stranger and demand
a know who they are what is going on
I understand they be confused but the
last two solid minutes has been all the
characters constantly asking a version
of this question you're short he's fat
she's hot and he's the rock let's move
on
I am Spencer I'm Spencer yep that's
Benson oh yeah I remember that character
trait about Spencer being paranoid that
hasn't come up since the very beginning
of the movie that's how he's ultimately
identified as being the real deal I'm an
overweight match man sweet I've been
looking for a sequel to the hot chick
and I finally got it you gotta love the
Jumanji game it doesn't even tell you
what these marks are Jumanji is a bigger
dick than mist at least you could quit
mist I have a tattoo I have one too
one it's the only explanation that old
game machine must have electrocuted
man I know Bethenny's annoying and all
but it's not like the other two didn't
see the hippo coming up the deep blue
see her we couldn't give her a heads up
it's moose it's not Mouse no good sir
I'm quite sure it's Mouse if Nigel can
only answer when he's been programmed
answer then how does he know to correct
Mouse on his name unless this is
something the programmers knew it would
be a common mistake we need your help
what if you think that I checked this
letter to make sure that Nigel read this
narration 100 percent correctly you're
right and he didn't if it wasn't that I
just send the narration you can see the
bind I'm in Van Pelt assumed dominion
over all of Jumanji screeches
controlling them then why doesn't he
have control over all these humans that
are standing around if he bosses his
henchmen around sure but Nigel's
completely unaffected right and remember
the goal he's made the same thing oh
here's a map of Jumanji
that's curious why didn't he just hand
over the map before he got caught in
that loop saying the same verse over and
over he's going to say the verse again
after this anyway well you can't just
give us a ride to the statue fridge
would be amazing at writing Lord of the
Rings why can't we just leave stop the
game without doing all this stuff
Jack Black it's the only one that's
actively trying to mimic his IRL
character and it's hilarious once enough
this is what I'm good at playing video
games it's what I do it's literally the
main thing that I do okay fine we saw
you playing a game briefly earlier in
this movie but there is nothing in this
movie that suggests you're a hardcore
gamer we've seen you help fridge cheat
on his paper more than we've seen you as
Wade wants but the problem is there's
nothing here what do you mean there's
nothing there it's a map just like he
said cartography I've got to wonder what
a Bethany decided not to go
and it was just Spencer fridge and
Martha would there be an AI professor
Shelley talking with them right now who
can read the map hey Leon Tala G what
does that even mean a few minutes ago
fridge discovered he possessed knowledge
he didn't even know he had because of
his character but Bethany doesn't know
what paleontology is huh strength is my
weakness
how is strength my weakness this is an
excellent question if they still have
most of the characteristics of their
real-life selves in this universe how do
these strengths and weaknesses apply
like it's I their only nothing right Mad
Max Jumanji Road Jesus but all this
firepower even in a game these guys
would be toast but apparently the video
game revert stew movie rules when it
comes to Amy why would the game have
this perspective every other shot has
been from the viewpoint of one of the
main characters so this flash to villain
vision is hooey
let me see you back inside
you're backtracked you have my weapons
we haven't even checked the goddamn
backpack until now he's been carrying
that the entire game get on my back
I would rather die on my back no I'm
gonna die character says there's no way
they will do something only to be doing
that very thing in the next scene cliche
jeez I'm so tired of seeing the main
characters chase through a wooded area
and suddenly come upon a cliff in every
action movie
see also Indiana Jones Pirates of the
Caribbean Star Trek the revenant Furious
7 are you saying that we can actually
die in here I mean I don't know for sure
I'm not sure you're not sure mr. video
game genius look I get that fridges
frustrated but this kind of an argument
even in a movie like this is silly it
makes it sound like fridge has zero
common sense as if he thinks Spencer
gets trapped in games all the time I
gotta take a leak first I've been
dreading us all day but so do I please
tell me one videogame outside of like
Leisure Suit Larry where a character has
to take a piss in the middle of a
mission also this sets up a scene of
Bethenny discovering how to pee as a man
which is so over long and unfunny that
I'm convinced it was originally supposed
to be in an animated kids movie
I guess jet blacks part was originally
meant to be played by Luis he came first
on if killing gravestone was so goddamn
important to Van Pelt why didn't he go
there himself I was something every
creature every soldier to hunt them down
why haven't you done that already
could you say that one more time please
with the smaller team you have control
of that or is that just happen naturally
it just happens naturally okay that got
me that's worth it's enough where the
hell is Jamaal he's supposed to be I
thought we were out in the fucking
jungle but this bizarre straight out of
late Istanbul it probably just meant
that I love cake that couldn't resist it
Jumanji somehow I made one of Finbar's
weaknesses cake which should probably
never come up during the game but
somehow it does because the movie
overrides the logic of the game and it's
hilarious to watch Kevin Hart explode I
have this map that like has a missing
piece dr. brace stone thank goodness
you're here we need to find the missing
piece if you're going to make a
cartographer the only character who can
read the map then why would you make
this character completely ignore the
only one who can read it and again News
playing brave stone if he's not selected
what you need is in the basket one false
move you're in a casket this riddle
reminds me that there's really been none
of this since the beginning of the game
I wasn't there a rhyme about the hippos
of the river or the mighty roar out in
the valley
yeah the best way to
sneak up on the people you're trying to
capture is to scream hey at the top of
your lungs rock blocking hello doctor
been a long time I believe you have
something that belongs to me
so is Van Pelt's supposed to be British
or not because if so I'm not buying this
kind of accent for a second
stay off the white bricks what and
freeze see flame sure does enjoy those
dramatic orders even though he could
have given them at any time long before
now looks like about su plan he must
have crawled out of this hole long
here's where the movie doesn't seem like
they're playing a video game anymore
this is a cutscene that the main
characters don't get to see and they're
discussing very specific details that a
game like this wouldn't be able to
comprehend man takes actions a video
game wouldn't bother what is the old
main villain kills one of his henchmen
because he screwed up chestnut how else
would we know this guy is evil if he
didn't do this who's Alan Parrish he's
the guy who built this place nice nod to
the original but it brings up a lot of
questions how did the videogame Jumanji
reconcile its world with board game
Jumanji video game Jumanji turned into a
completely different game with different
set of rules namely you can get out of
this place if you can get to the end
Alan had no such luck because future
Bonnie Hunt ran away from the game and
the original those keeping him stuck
here I realized that with upgrades come
different rules but what this game did
to Alan Parrish is one of the bigger
dick moves I can remember once I got
down to my last life I realized I was
screwed and then I was never gonna get
out of here by myself ok let me take
that back
Jumanji the video game basically did the
same thing to camp rocks Nick Jonas that
it did down in Parrish from only this
time there was no way to know that other
people needed to play the game let's not
forget that Jumanji specifically changed
into a video game because when Alex
wasn't being played by Nick Jonas he
said who plays board games I've never
once said hey man you need five players
for this even bigger dick move the
game's objective is to save Jumanji and
Jumanji is a colossal asshole
half the stuff that came at me I had
zero way to deal with now you can't kill
a black mom with a margarita then how
the hell did Alex get to the
transportation shed level or really
through any of the levels up till now
you're our missing piece you were the
thing that we needed to find yeah but
the game told them about the missing
piece and had they gone in with all the
five players what would the missing
piece be then also Bethany is right but
how is that possible and why would
anyone make the connection they'd need
to find a fifth character if camp rocked
to the final jams Nick Jonas doesn't
happen to be wandering around the bazaar
after they did the snake challenge they
never find this guy unless the game
itself somehow made it happen
also also there were only four
controllers on the console so the game
was setting these assholes up for
failure from the get-go
get past these guards last time I just
waited somebody left how long did that
take three weeks we find out later these
guards are true video game characters
who are stuck in some sort of loop so
why did they ever leave the post
distracting guys is like the main thing
I do he plays video games i distract
guys
she don't exactly have the toolkit not
me
Bethany basically played a whole new
level of pronoun game here but
apparently she knew she was in a movie
and was ready to make a big dramatic
reveal also do they really not have
enough weapons to take out two guards
pinbar has a whole sack of weapons he
could get brave stone and Ruby
roundhouse knows all the martial arts
okay let's talk about your walk take
your time
my favorite a woman the Pygmalion
Diaries like this I think you're ready
this flirt mission literally has no time
constraints so why not practice on the
rock and Kevin Hart before going down
there oh yeah so they can create another
funny situation damn I keep forgetting
that
she's pretty fly and those guys don't
meet a lot of new people flaw sure alex
is from 1996 but he's also a fucking
metalhead according to his room decor
and I don't remember any metalheads in
1996 using the word fly to describe a
hot girl I'm just saying I'm sure they'd
like to get jiggy with us nobody was
saying jiggy in 1996 either the word
only gained steam in 1998 when Will
Smith released getting jiggy wit it from
his Big Willie style album hello little
lady what are you doing out here all
alone
how does every NPC in this game not know
who Ruby is she's one of only five main
characters in the game you guys like it
yes it might not be a dance-off but it's
still solving problems with dancing
which is the odd thing every movie must
have nowadays
so are these NPCs getting turned on by
this they obviously aren't paying
attention to their work even though they
repeat the same phrase over and over is
the power of digital boners greater than
the power of surveillance Ruby's
strength this dance fighting but is this
really it she's not really fucking
dancing at all just kicking regular ass
with music in the background look good
for this henchman role but the xenia
onatopp seems like an extremely
inefficient fight move that's nice but
wouldn't this destroy the helicopter and
yet when Spencer throws fruit off the
helicopter they all chase after it I
don't get you Monty
sometimes the solutions are impossible
and sometimes they are we too easy also
if Van Pelt's still has control of all
the animals in Jumanji why can't one of
the Rhinos pick up the jewel in its
mouth and take it back
to it every one of these rhinos has a
murder boner that's so strong that they
disregard what has to be the most
important thing in their universe oh
right I know Spencer the rock Gilpin is
confident in his catching abilities but
what if he misses here the gamble to
push fridge out of the chopper was made
after seeing that he had two lives left
but if fridge falls here he's back among
the rhinos and his totally fucking dead
man also why would you risk everyone's
life for this maneuver I guess they did
a recent course on collateral damage in
this high school why did they land here
even if the map hasn't revealed the
ultimate location of the Jaguar they
should be flying around looking for it
right let's go oh yeah let's not forget
they gave this already unlucky character
a weakness that gives him a highly
likely chance of dying considering the
mosquito population in Jumanji this is
kinda clever but it's totally random
it's more CPR ex machina than something
they came up with intuitively I just
keep thinking about my poor parents what
they must have been through why because
I was sitting in my hideout too afraid
to finish the game yeah but could you
have finish the game without the four
other players the movie has been pretty
clear that you were once you came in
here alone jump squirrel also if you're
going to point out that climbing is won
a brave stone strengths then I'm
compelled to tell you that one of the
other strengths is that he is fearless
as well so get the fuck out of here with
the squirrels
a good friend fetch happened with these
two to bring them back together as
friends they've literally both killed
each other this afternoon alone and
they're still bickering up until this
point this works
fridge is able to reason with a wild
elephant apparently because he is a
zoologist and all zoologist no elephant
language I can't give you the jewel
because I don't have it geez dude you
could have said that a lot earlier it's
not like you knew fruits would come
crashing through riding an elephant
right about now elephant begin the climb
it now feels like this movie is just
making it up as it goes along
the only reason an elephant is here is
because a series of random events
occurred this jumping is so fake they
might as well put Mario sounds with it
in fact let's rewind this and do just
that I'll take that man Van Pelt's
spends an awful lot of time saying give
it to me and I'll take that when he
could literally walk over and take that
or have one of his thousands of animals
he controls take that also how do you
get up here besides the hit-or-miss
Animal Control in Jumanji what are van
Pelt powers its movie interested in
explaining natch to us is this
motorcycle really driving up a steeper
rocki almost completely vertical I'm
game cheats on where people respawn
after their death and puts Martha closer
to the Jaguar than she wants before hell
of a game too bad it doesn't have much
replay value
oh no not stuck villain character 118
played by an overqualified actor aka the
anti kill monger where's Alex so did
they all just walk the hell out of
detention because I'm pretty sure they
didn't make a dent in those magazine
staples Hey look hate to break it to
everyone but getting Alex back to his
home in 1996 would have changed a lot
more than this there's a chance these
kids aren't even born when they get back
since they effectively changed the past
and even the slightest change would have
caused some sort of sound a butterfly or
Thunder effect hey Dad were you give me
a second
not only the kids walk up on Alex at the
exact minute his expositional minivan
shows up he somehow recognizes four
adolescents that look nothing like the
avatars he played with over 20 years ago
Bethany
Spencer yeah Ruby Brown house that would
make you fridge did he never learn
Martha's real name Martha why didn't you
say Martha go get that girl doctor
gravestone so Bethany has embraced
nature and wants to go back packing
Spencer and Martha are working on
hooking up and coming out of their
shells so what's up with fridge is he
like gonna do his own homework now I
mean it seems like everyone else has
some real character growth after the
game last time they kissed it was a
sloppy pretty much total failure now
they're pros on the second try
yeah like the hell stop a sequel
don't you understand I found a cure for
the fucking plague of the 20th century
and now I've lost don't understand the
obsession with throwing the ball new
hoop and Oh touchdown five points hello
doctor doctor doctor doctor doctor
doctor the fourth dimension will
collapse upon itself you stupid bitch
welcome to detention you have exactly
eight hours and 54 minutes to think
about why what happens if we use up all
our lives
well usually that would mean Bethenny
you're a girl